it's opening day for tesla and its
electric car factory near berlin
after two years of construction tesla's
first european factory delivers its
first cars today
the berlin brandenburg gigafactory could
soon be building half a million cars per
year
tesla is also building a battery factory
nearby
berlin is tesla's fourth car factory its
first plant in california went into
operation in california in 2010 it also
opened a factory in 2016 in the nevada
desert then came its shanghai plant in
2019 berlin brandenburg factory opening
today here in 2022
up next a new giga factory will be
opening in austin texas uh hopefully
soon
now we'll talk to our correspondent who
is there at the berlin brandon
brandenburg factory in a moment but
first let's take a look at this project
this was a forest just two years ago but
it was cleared to make way for a massive
construction site
europe's largest factory for electric
cars was built on three square
kilometers of land just outside berlin
tesla invested billions of euros into
the project
construction has been quick by german
standards but with some hitches the
factory was built at the company's own
risk without waiting for a final
building permit environmental protests
forced tesla to change plants a dispute
remains about the factory's water
supplies
all of these were a source of
frustration for tesla
i think there could be
less bureaucracy that would be better
construction was supposed to be
completed in summer 2021 but it took
until march this year for that final
building permit to arrive
spread out over 23 000 documents
the notice of approval for this project
has been handed over to tesla today
now it can get started
000 cars can be built here per year with
12 000 employees once everything is
fully operational
the factory could help europe take a
significant step away from petroleum and
throws down the gauntlet to other car
makers to go electric
dw stephen beardsley is at the factory
gates he joins me now
steven tesla the biggest name in
electric vehicles but germany also has a
lot of more traditional car makers like
volkswagen that are getting very serious
about electrum ability what will this
factory mean for competition
well chelsea tesla built this factory
here this massive production hall you
see behind me for the same reason that
volkswagen or audi or bmw builds in
markets where it's selling that's for
example in the us or in china it's
basically a better investment of their
capital to serve those markets now the
model wise that are going to be built
here were coming from places like
shanghai from a car factory in
california now they can be built here
they can be sold in this market that's a
massive cost reduction for tesla it
allows them to be here in europe where
they see a growing growing market now
you mentioned some of the competitors
volkswagen audi they are really kicking
up their efforts with evs volkswagen
almost doubling its sales in one quarter
alone
of evs last year it's on 80 percent
increase over the whole year so it's
coming on fast but right now tesla is
the world leader and in things like
software and things like production
methods in managerial style
it is sort of more the modern car maker
it's seen that way by a lot of
a lot of experts including some of uh
the leaders in the car industry
including hebrides who leads volkswagen
he's made it very clear that his plan is
to try and take over tesla in the coming
years but that's still going to take a
while tesla right now is the world
leader and with this hall that is
opening right now this is another big
step forward for the producer
so stephen tesla did want to open this
back to you earlier as early as uh last
summer but as we heard in the report
they've faced a lot of bureaucracy how
big of an issue is that for companies
you know building factories here in
germany
well for tesla it's this factory comes
about six months later than they had
hoped for they had hoped that october as
a realistic date for it to open now
originally as you mentioned september
i'm sorry summer was what was being eyed
but then tesla came back and said that
they wanted to build a battery
production facility as well and that
lengthened this process for receiving
approval now it only took two and a half
years to build this i say only because
in germany that's actually a very good
timeline and
a lot of officials and a lot of
politicians are looking at tesla and
this approval process as perhaps the way
to move forward to try and speed up
some major projects as you mentioned
that they're eyeing in the future you
look at right now with energy concerns
with the need to build lng terminals
with the need to build renewable energy
the approval process is considerably
long here in germany they want to see it
sped up and tesla might be something
like a blueprint for that
so stephen this factory also
faced a lot of resistance particularly
from environmental groups is the
community around the factory now
satisfied
i think it depends which community we're
talking about when you look at
brandenburg in general this is a region
outside of berlin that's very thinly
populated it hasn't had as many
industrial
plants here industrial employers here
that might offer jobs like in other
parts of germany so this is very much
welcome from a job perspective the local
community has been a little upset about
water issues here that will continue to
be a problem this facility is going to
need the water of about a 40 000
population city
per year so that is something that is
going to take a massive resource from
this area it's probably going to require
more wells to be dug
for residents of this area
but the officials here say that the
water is there and that it's not a
problem so that has been an issue there
were also some concerns about
raising this area for the factory but
for the most part that's been put to the
side and many of the questions have been
answered
steven beardsley thanks so much
now tesla is just one example of the big
foreign companies who flock to europe's
biggest economy in recent years take a
look at some of the others
this battery factory opened its doors in
2021 and scalefia in northern sweden
it is the first of its kind to be built
by a european company
the swedish company northvolt may only
have been in business since 2016
but it plans to build a battery factory
in northern germany thanks to the
region's eco-friendly power production
and the company can expect substantial
government help
germany needs new batteries to power its
pivot towards green energy
there are also big plans for macdeburg
in eastern germany
u.s chip manufacturer intel wants to
spend 17 billion euros in the region to
open two new factories that would employ
3 000 people
and its banking on european union
subsidies to the tune of several billion
euros
construction is due to start next year
both announcements are likely to give
germany's economy a major boost
in the last several years the amount of
direct investment in germany has been
continually increasing
raising some 10 percent over the last
five years
with the majority of it coming from the
united states
carmaker ford has been working in
germany since 1926
now it's shifting its production to
electric cars
and spending two billion dollars to do
it
at this factory near cologne two new
models will hit the roads starting in
2024.
i'm joined now by robert tehrmann from
germany trade and invest which is the
government's economic promotion
agency robert thanks so much for being
here so germany has been criticized for
a long time for being too slow too
bureaucratic to attract you know foreign
investment is that narrative starting to
change
um of course i think um we have seen
that through the settlement of tesla's
or the decision of tesla to to locate a
manufacturing plant in brandenburg and
you see that um by the investment
decisions of the just mentioned intel
and northworld so there is a clear sign
for the opportunities for large
companies to settle
manufacturing activities into germany
you mentioned tesla we're talking a lot
today about tesla since it is the grand
opening of that factory outside of
berlin
you know elon musk has been quite
critical of german bureaucracy they
wanted to open that factory about a year
ago almost does a very public example
like that of sort of administrative
bureaucratic delays scare other
companies away from germany
i think
it might even even be the
opposite so i think
tesla has proven that you can have
approval processes done in two years for
such a huge investment um that's
outstanding for i would even say europe
um so it's a very very good sign for the
administration and reliable
administration in germany and i think
pat gelsinger has mentioned that in his
um the ceo of inter has mentioned that
in his speech last tuesday
that he very much
appreciates the reliable admin reliable
administration processes and
administration in germany so
tesla as well as citl and battery
manufacturer that
has located their manufacturing plant to
turingia
also two three years ago
show that the administration processes
are
competitive
so you mentioned intel there another big
win for germany as an investment
location
the german government reportedly is
giving intel around 5 billion euros in
subsidies why should taxpayer money be
given to these big corporations to
attract them here
the benefit that you that the german
economy is getting and even the european
economy is getting out of those projects
those very large projects it's much
higher than the amount of incentives and
subsidies paid by the german government
if you see
the whole infrastructure the
ecosystem that is expected around such a
huge investment with thousands of jobs
intel published that they will create
another 10 000 jobs indirect
to their investment activities so the
benefit coming out of those projects is
much higher than the amount paid for
starting such an activity and
you have to also consider
subsidies are part of investing
internationally so um the amount that is
paid in in europe and in germany this
time um is
not that high as it would be in for
example korea taiwan china or united
states so i think it's that is part of
attracting that is part of developing um
sustainable future technologies in
regions and i think that's part of the
commitment of the government to support
those developments just briefly if you
can you know a key strategy for the new
german government also for the eu is is
making us less dependent on technology
from the us or asia what needs to be
done to achieve that
i think um the the framework that i just
mentioned the
incentive scheme the clear
focus on certain industry sectors is
very important and the european
commission is focusing on certain
aspects the german government is
focusing on certain industry topics um
so a clear focus is helpful um the
german government decided on developing
a sustainable energy supply for example
so the clear focus is relevant i think
we're gonna have to leave it there sorry
we're out of time thank you so much for
joining us